die Nachricht des Tages kommt aus Bayern
darauf haben viele gewartet in Bayern
und in Sachsen-Anhalt fällt jetzt die
maskenpflicht in Bussen und Bahnen und
einer hat sich natürlich sofort zu Wort
gemeldet Gesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach er tritt mal wieder auf die
Bremse er sagt rücksichts der anders der
Rest von Deutschland muss also weiter
Maske tragen so wie sonst eigentlich
nirgends in Europa das ist eines unserer
Themen hier heute bei 8:15 Uhr Frage in
Bayern setzt man auf Freiwilligkeit
tragen sie weiter die Maske oder ziehen
Sie jetzt ab also ich trage die Maske
nicht und ich denke dass jeder das
selbst entscheiden muss ich freue mich
dass Bayern sich dazu hat durchringen
können natürlich liegt auf der Hand
woran das liegt der Wahlkampf steht
bevor und Herr Söder hat einen
untrügliches Gespür dafür wie das
Volksstimmung ist gleichwohl ist die
Entscheidung richtig und ich gehe davon
aus dass auch die weiteren nach und nach
die Länder nachziehen es ist gerade zu
Kafka ist dass die Situation die wir in
Deutschland haben es ist äh wir sind
schon seit längerem Geisterfahrer wenn
wir um uns herumschauen eine der letzten
Länder die die maskenpflicht aufhebt und
es ist absolut notwendig jetzt in die
Eigenverantwortung zu gehen es ist
eigentlich schon viel zu spät also jetzt
zu sagen ein Glück ist das jetzt der
Fall eigentlich müsste man sagen es ist
viel zu spät und natürlich muss auch die
der Bund jetzt nachziehen und im
Fernverkehr natürlich auch die
maskenpflicht aufheben und zwar diesen
Winter denn wenn wir das diesen Winter
nicht schaffen dann werden wir das alle
Jahre viele erleben es fängt ja schon an
so naja auch für andere Viren und so
weiter es muss diesen Winter gelingen
sonst haben wir die Maßnahmen auch in
Zukunft Frau Abi bei ihnen in Mannheim
sie kommen aus Mannheim angereist da
diskutiert man ja sogar darüber die
maskenpflicht noch zu verschärfen was
halten Sie davon wie gehen Sie damit um
ich schalte das okay also in
öffentlicher Verkehrsmittel finde ich
schon gut und wie fühlen sie sich dabei
das ist so unterschiedliche Regelungen
gibt das ist eine Bundesland das macht
das andere macht jenes viele Fragen ja
es wäre natürlich schöner wenn alle
Bundesländer das gleiche tun
man wünscht sich Einheitlichkeit und
viele fragen sich wo bleibt die
Einheitlichkeit wann zieht in Berlin
eigentlich nach sie beschäftigen sich ja
hier in Berlin auch mit
Gesundheitsthemen unter anderem ziehen
wir da irgendwie nachziehen die anderen
irgendwann
dass wir nachziehen ich glaube das ist
höchste Zeit ist dass wir die
maskenpflicht abschaffen wir sind auch
der Meinung dass man die
insulationspflicht endlich abschaffen
muss gleichzeitig erlebe ich aber auch
vor wenigen Wochen noch die Diskussion
der Gesundheit Senatorin in Berlin die
überlegt die maskenpflicht in Berlin
wieder einzuführen
das ist meines Erachtens völlige
Realitätsverweigerung wieder
mittlerweile herrscht und ich erlebe es
auch immer im Parlament und auch
Lauterbach will das ja auch Lauterbach
will es und für mich ist es mittlerweile
so eine Art Gutmenschen tun würde ich
sagen die Maske ganz Symbole stets zu
tragen auf Freiwilligkeit ja jeder so
wie er will aber gerade die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Grünen Partei tragen
ist schon fast wie eine Monstranz oft
vor sich her und da muss man sich
wirklich mal fragen wann komm mal wieder
zurück zur Vernunft wann kommen wir
zurück zur Vernunft man könnte sagen es
ist so ein bisschen so ein typischer
polit Steuersatz oder Jan wann kommen
wir zurück zur vernünftigen sagen da ist
die andere sagen jedes Mal rudert hin
mein rudert wieder zurück und keiner ist
geeinigt also man hat ja immer Markus
Söder oder hat sich ja selbst als
Mitglied des Team Vorsicht bezeichnet
und das was er jetzt macht die sagen das
ist ein Wahlkampftrick kann man
sicherlich auch so stehen lassen
nächstes Jahr im Herbst für den Bayern
gewinnen möglicherweise ist Markus
wieder weiterhin im Team Vorsicht weil
er weiß dass das Maske tragen und wir
sehen ja das an den hohen
Infektionszahlen mit anderen Viren auch
dazu führt dass man natürlich so sagen
es zumindest Experten Mediziner dann
nimmt viel anfälliger reagiert auf
andere Krankheiten wenn man zu lange
Maske trägt gerade dann wenn es gar
nicht nötig ist von daher wäre jetzt
meine These einerseits natürlich ein
Wahlkampfmanöver aber andererseits
bleibt Markus Söder im Team vorsicht
aber diesmal denkt ja halt an andere
Viren und ähm versucht da also
vorzubeugen ist Schleswig-Holstein ist
auch ein Bundesland was den nehmen die
maskenpflicht der abschaffen will
Sachsen-Anhalt auch gemacht deswegen das
ist glaube ich also ein wichtiger Punkt
der gemacht wird sie haben gerade gesagt
auch die Einheitlichkeit muss
hergestellt weiß ich gar nicht lasst
doch die Bundesländer unterschiedliche
Dinge ausprobieren das werden die Wähler
am Ende schon richten was sie dann für
besser halten und wenn der Hamburger
erste Bürgermeister Tschentscher der
Meinung ist es muss bis irgendwie april
oder März hat er glaube ich gesagt die
Maske weiter getragen werden in Bussen
und Bahnen dann soll er das doch machen
man fragt sich bloß warum man aus Kiel
kommt mit dem Zug dann durch
Schleswig-Holstein keine Maske trägt
aber sobald man die Hamburger
Stadtgrenze dann mit dem gleichen Zug
mit den gleichen Leuten über Teil
überfährt deine Maske tragen muss das
ist Gaga in der Tat und ich stimme Ihnen
voll und ganz zu ähm die maskenpflicht
muss fallen auch im Fernverkehr ganz
anders absurd ist es natürlich auch wenn
wir sehen Leben in Restaurants auf
Konzerten in Clubs es ist voll jeder die
Menschen tragen ganz überwiegend keine
Maske und dann aber zu sagen im
öffentlichen Person Nahverkehr da muss
das aber sein also das meine ich auch
damit dass es wirklich also völlig
abstrus einfach ist zu sagen nee daran
halten wir jetzt fest und auch das Karl
Lauterbach jetzt wieder sofort Recht und
sagt nee und Bayern setzt sich über das
Infektionsschutzgesetz hinweg er hat ich
will das ein eigenes Gesetz nicht
verstanden oder macht ganz billig muss
man schon sagen Stimmung ja und das ist
unreden ihnen sitzt ja Frau alperteile
sie haben ihre ganz eigene Geschichte
die wollen Sie uns auch im Zuge dieser
Sendung noch erzählen fühlen sie sich
mit der Maske sicherer
nein
nein aber wenn sagen wir so es muss
freiwillig sein also ich finde es ist
nicht sicherer das heißt es gibt
Situationen da fühlen Sie sich gut und
lassen sie weg und sie entscheiden das
gerne auch selbst ich möchte gerne
selber entscheiden nicht dass ein Gesetz
kommt und sagt hier im Krankenhaus oder
öffentlich aber wie gesagt wenn jemand
freiwillig das aufsetzen möchte darf
nicht verboten werden aber es darf nicht
gesetzt also geflogen
gesagt also es ist ja völlig schizophren
und den Leuten nicht erklärbar ich lande
mit dem Flieger am BER ohne Maske
steigen die S-Bahn du machst eine Maske
tragen sitzt mit dem gleichen Menschen
aus dem Flieger noch zusammen ne also
das ist was das versteht keiner mehr und
da muss glaube ich einfach auch wir alle
mal wieder zusammen uns darauf befinden
dass es ein vernünftigen normalen
Menschenverstand gibt und da weiß ich
war nicht die Maske anzuziehen habe und
wann ich sie nicht anziehen kann habe
ich gelernt haben dass man jetzt nicht
mehr sagen kann die Wissenschaft wir
haben im Zuge dieser Krise gelernt das
ist die Wissenschaft nicht als einzelne
Wissenschaft gibt dass es viele
verschiedene Theorien viele Studien und
so weiter gibt wann ist es denn an der
Zeit auch den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
mehr Eigenverantwortung zu geben die
Verantwortung vor einem Jahr sehen Sie
wann war die Zeit wer die richtige Frage
wahrscheinlich gewesen oder
ja wann war die Zeit also ich glaube
dass wir hätten weiter sein können jetzt
schon ich frag mich auch wenn beim
Fernverkehr zum Beispiel aber das Thema
Eigenverantwortung an die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger zurückgeben ist ja nicht nur
in der Gesundheitspolitik ein Thema
sondern in ganz ganz vielen Themen und
ich glaube da müssen wir wieder zurück
aber das ist glaube ich jetzt was da
würden wir wahrscheinlich den Rahmen der
Sendung springen wenn wir jetzt anfangen
wo wir das Thema Eigenverantwortung
wieder im Staatswesen überhaupt brauchen
können wir über das Thema Verbeamtung
Verwaltung
pensionskassenkrankenkasse und etc
sprechen aber da muss was geschehen und
ich glaube das ist was was die Menschen
auch wirklich spüren was mich bei Karl
Lauterbach der ist ja nun ja auch schon
mehrmals erwähnt worden wirklich muss
ich sagen extrem mittlerweile stört es
eigentlich dass er seit er im Amt ist
vor immer neuen Wellen waren warnt und
wenn wir zurückschauen letzten vier fünf
Monate dann gab es eigentlich im Sommer
schon von Karl Lauterbach auch die ganz
ganz große Warnung vor der wirklich
gefährlichen Herbst Welle und dann auch
einer winterwelle und wir stellen fest
dass wir einigermaßen gut durch den
Herbst gekommen sind weil einfach alle
nahezu alle Menschen mit irgend in
irgendeiner Art und Weise mit dem Virus
ja schon in Kontakt gekommen sind sei es
durch Impfung sei es durch eine
Infektion und stellen auch fest dass
interessanterweise wenn man darauf noch
wertlich die Inzidenzen im Oktober viel
viel höher waren als beispielsweise im
November die Welle also ganz von selbst
ohne dass wir irgendwer Lockdown hatten
oder verschärfende Maßnahmen wieder
gebrochen ist und das ist doch
erstaunlich und jetzt warnt Karl
Lauterbach seit Wochen weiterhin vor der
großen gefährlichen winterwelle die
jetzt kommen soll ich kann jeden Tag
sagen um Gottes Willen ich glaube heute
Abend geht die Sonne unter es wird
irgendwann so passieren dann fühlt sich
Karl Lauterbach möglicherweise ein recht
dass er vor einer Welle gewarnt hat das
Problem ist nur er macht ist schon seit
Monaten und verunsichert natürlich
permanent die Bevölkerung genau
verunsichert
in Ordnung aber er verunsichert
permanent die Bevölkerung und hat immer
noch diesen diesen krisenmodus damit
Marker bei vielen hier bei uns in der
Runde nicht mehr durchdringen aber bei
vielen anderen Menschen noch und die
kommen aus diesem krisenmodus gar nicht
heraus und das ist glaube ich extrem
schlecht unter anderem auch für die
Psyche oder sehr beim nächsten Problem
so und da muss der Gesundheitsminister
interessanterweise auch mal drüber
nachdenken was er mit seiner
panik-politik eigentlich an anderen
negativen Folgen Anrichte